yeah we have uh this population
uh vendors who are primarily immigrant
primarily Latino and these folks are
just trying to provide
um for their families a lot of uh these
folks use this as an Avenue as a primary
income or a secondary income for their
families and for for a lot of them this
is their American Dream right their
their them operating their own small
businesses being Their Own Boss
um
and again this this bill supports them
in achieving their version of the
American dream I believe
your question uh it was important to our
membership I make the road Nevada
um and us as an organization as well to
make sure that we protected uh the
residential areas uh for our local
vendors that is primarily where our
local folks operate and uh we feel that
this piece of legislation does that um
and our vendors or excuse me our members
uh our vendor members I should say are
are happy and they feel that this bill
does that as well